claude nougaro j'ai bien envie de vous
poser la question bien classique
est ce que vous êtes content de l'avoir
gagné le bruit bien je me croyais un
cancre dans la chanson et j'apprends
tout à coup que je suis un très bon
élève alors je suis agréablement surpris
avant de chanter
que faisiez-vous j'écrivais des poèmes
de des bois inspirées par des femmes
mais aucune l'elysée elle préférait
danser sur des disques bourré de
chanteurs de rythme alors je me suis
mise à chanter j'ai mis de la musique
rythmique sur l'un de mes anciens poèmes
le voici mesdames mesdemoiselles
tiens toi bien à mon coeur qui entourent
voit bien là mon coeur car l'amour ça va
ça va ça va vite
accroche toi bien là mon coeur tout
autour de nous le monde et ont fui de
l'amour tu ne savais pas ça fonce tout
droit soudain larmes que nous qui te ya
un mur virage est le beau voyage qui
vole en éclats il m'arrive de me
réveiller le matin et de me dire qu'est
ce que tu fais dans la vie je chantais
et je trouve que c'est pas tout à fait
pas très sérieux
je suis un peu toujours un peu
désorienté faire ce métier surtout
peut-être l'heure actuellement écrire
des chansons s'est passé ri chanté des
chansons ça peut être considéré avec
plus de sympathie parce qu'il ya une
action physique
il ya des risques concrets qui mérite
une certaine estime on vous l'avez petit
vertigineusement peut-il fils a
rassemblé mots et les marques
comme le fait si vous faisiez les pages
froissé de nous
non